Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain a short Drama film called
“The Karman Line.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
The protagonist of the movie is a middle-aged
housewife named Sarah. She lives with her
teenage daughter Carly and her husband Dave.
One afternoon Sarah is in a delightful mood.
She is blasting a romantic song on the
radio and is dancing around the house.
At the same time, Carly returns home from school
and is in a seemingly bad mood. She takes off her
dirty shoes and carelessly tosses them away. Her
mother tries to lighten her mood by dancing and
singing around her but she doesn’t acknowledge
it, and rather finds it annoying. Sarah follows
her to the kitchen while still dancing but Carly
simply turns the radio’s volume down and takes
the dinner plate from the counter. It is evident
that Carly doesn’t appreciate her mother's efforts
and takes her for granted. Sarah, however, doesn't
seem to mind her daughter’s indifference. She
simply turns the volume back up and checks Carly’s
bag to see if she has eaten all her food.
Sarah then finds a test paper inside her
bag that has very bad grades. Although it
is only a mock test she urges her daughter to
do better. Carly, again ignores her which has
become sort of a routine in the household. When
Sarah asks for an answer, she simply walks away
to her room. Moments later, Sarah picks up her
drink from the living room’s coffee table but it
drops from her hand. She starts to panic and yells
for help as her feet begin to move on their own.
Carly hears her cry and quickly runs downstairs
to see her mother is levitating off the ground.
She is too stunned to speak. In the following
scene, three men are trying to bring Sarah back
to the ground. One of them is her husband Dave.
He holds her hand for emotional support as the
other two guys pull Sarah down. They try their
best but do not succeed. It is almost as if they
are working against a mysterious force that is
keeping her afloat. No matter how much they try,
she doesn’t budge from her place.
Carly watches them from the door, not
being able to comprehend what is going on. The men
leave a while later but Sarah keeps levitating.
Dave then calls their family doctor, Dr. Behringer
to inspect the situation. He measures the distance
she has elevated from the ground and finds
out that she is going higher over time.
This worries the entire family. Even the doctor
does not have an answer as to how it is possible.
He simply takes her blood sample to study it and
hopefully find out why gravity has stopped working
on her. He also promises to send in a consultant,
Dr. Benham who can potentially help her. The
husband asks him how long it will take but the
doctor assures them that since Sarah is healthy,
there are all the reasons to believe she will
be better in no time. Starting that day, Sarah
cannot move around and keeps on flying upwards. In
only one day, she stands taller than her husband.
Dave buys a bedpan to help her defecate but their
hopes of her getting better are fading with time.
Since she cannot move from the room, the father
and daughter redecorate it to fit her needs and
keep her entertained. Soon, Sarah’s sisters
also come to her house to help her with life.
It is almost as if she is bedridden
and needs people to take care of her.
They clean up after her every day. Eventually,
they start needing a ladder to reach her.
Dr. Behringer visits regularly to check up on
Sarah and measure how much she has elevated
since the last time. He keeps track of the maths
and finds out that she is being pulled up at a
higher rate as time passes by. To stop this, he
makes her wear a belt with weights inside of it so
the weights would decrease the rate of elevation.
However, this doesn’t help Sarah’s case and she
almost reaches the ceiling. Dave starts getting
frustrated seeing no results out of the doctor’s
experiments. At night, Sarah starts wrapping a
blanket around herself while sleeping on air.
Dave loves his wife dearly and makes sure to
be with her all the time. He has shifted from
the bedroom to the living room to be with her
at night in case she needs anything. Sarah’s
consultant Dr. Mary Benham only arrives after
a week. By the time, Sarah is on the ceiling,
struggling to go further up. The doctor introduces
herself and reaches out to shake her hand.
She apologizes for not getting there sooner and
inquires how they are coping with the situation.
Dave jokes and says that the ceiling is
not a convenient place to keep a wife.
For some reason, the doctor doesn’t seem to be
surprised by Sarah’s condition. She simply brings
out a measuring tape and measures the distance
between her and the floor. Dave offers the doctor
a cup of tea and sends Carly to make it. Without
Sarah’s help, the kitchen is a complete mess.
Carly brings out a dirty mug from the sink and
simply rinses it before pouring tea in it and
handing it to the doctor. After realizing the
severeness of Sarah’s condition, the doctor’s
demeanor changes. The family had been waiting
for her to come and miraculously cure Sarah,
but they soon realise that she, too, has no idea
what the problem is. The doctor bluntly tells
the family that their case is unique, so nothing
is certain. From what the doctors have seen and
studied, Sarah will continue to move upwards at
a variable but increasing rate. Dave hesitantly
asks the doctor if she can bring Sarah down to
which she apologizes and says she can’t.
The weights will slow her process but if she
carries more of it, it will injure her. Their
best bet is to wait for the condition to go away
on its own. In about ten weeks, Sarah will reach a
height of twelve thousand feet. From there, she
will need oxygen to survive. Even after that,
she will still keep rising upwards and they will
have to keep her warm and control her diet. Sarah
finally comes to the conclusion that she cannot
be saved. The family also acknowledges she is
going to rise to the sky until her inevitable
death. Carly comments that her mother is going
into orbit. Dave loses patience and demands the
doctor to do something but she says she can only
do the best to keep her comfortable but there is
no known way to save her. At night, Dave cuts the
floor around Sarah’s head to let her fly up. He is
aggressive while cutting it and almost hurts her.
As the dust falls on the poor woman, she calls
for her daughter for help. However, Carly
entirely ignores her mother’s pleas and turns
the tap on to not hear her. Eventually, Dave
completes making the hole and holds his wife's
hand. Sarah’s head is now inside Carly’s room.
She is clearly bothered by her mother invading her
privacy although she has no control over it.
The following day, Carly is studying for her
final exams as Sarah watches her in silence.
She has to pee but doesn’t want to disturb her
daughter. Sometime later, she apologizes and
asks Carly to call her father. Carly simply brings
the bedpan and helps her. Following that, she sits
back to study but cannot focus with her mother
in the room. Carly tells her that she cannot take
the exams this year because of the situation but
Sarah lashes out at her. She doesn’t want to be
a drawback in her daughter’s life. Some days later
is Dave and Sarah’s anniversary. They have invited
Sarah’s sister to dress her up for the occasion.
Dave compliments her, saying that she looks like
an angel, and the two laugh at the irony. Even
at the time of crisis, the couple celebrates and
drinks together. Dave gets on a table and kisses
her. Eventually, the two have intercourse. When
Carly returns home from school one day, she hears
her mother moaning in pain. It turns out that Dave
has tied her leg to the ground to keep her from
flying away which is really painful for her. He
sits on the door, not being able to watch his wife
whimper in misery. Carly quickly runs upstairs and
gets a knife to cut the rope. In the following
scene, Sarah has reached outside the house.
Dave and Carly reach her using a crane to hand
her food and supplies. This is probably the last
time they are going to see her, so they pack
her with enough food, oxygen, and water for
her journey to the sky. Carly hands her a phone
and a battery to call home when needed. She has
also brought a music player so Sarah can listen
to all her favorite songs when she gets bored.
Following that, she is made to wear a heavy
backpack so she would elevate at a slower speed.
As the daughter hands her the rations, Dave stays
quiet and only watches them. Before leaving, he
hugs his wife tightly, knowing that she is never
coming back. The family shares a tearful goodbye.
The next day, we see Sarah way high up in the sky.
She is hardly visible from the ground. To pass
time, she is invested in a crossword puzzle.
Suddenly, a drop of water falls on her book.
As she wipes it away it starts to drizzle. She
takes off her hat and wears the hood of her jacket
to keep warm. Some more days later, Sarah uses
binoculars to look down at the earth. She brings
out a packet of biscuits that Carly had given
her and sees that she is almost out of them.
She calls Carly and asks her what she is
cooking for herself. Without her mother,
she has started to eat baked beans and
toast every day. Sarah worries about her
and tells her to eat well-cooked food, but
Carly is clearly not interested in talking.
She answers in single words, mostly because
it is overwhelming to talk to her mother,
knowing that she will die one of these days. Sarah
apologizes for disturbing her and claims that she
misses her but Carly hangs up the call before she
can finish. Sarah gets emotional after the call,
so she brings out her music player to help her
calm down. But to her misfortune, she accidentally
drops it. For some seconds, she loses her calm
and screams in frustration. Her screams invite a
flock of birds towards her which instantly cheers
her mood. She waves her hands around happily in
between them. Dave misses his wife dearly and
resorts to alcoholism to get rid of the pain.
One night, it starts to rain heavily. Although
Sarah is wearing thick clothes, they are not
enough to keep her warm. She misses her family
but can do nothing about it. She somehow survives
the night, holding herself to keep warm.
The following day, she reaches higher in the
sky and now requires an oxygen mask to survive.
She removes the mask and calls her husband.
Dave runs to the phone and asks her if she is
doing well. Carly also comes running worried
about her mother. Sarah tells Carly that even
if she fails her exams, she is very proud of her
and will always love her. Dave repeatedly
asks her to put the oxygen mask back on
but she refuses. Instead, she asks them to stand
away from the hole in the ceiling. Seconds later,
a bag falls through it. The two register that
Sarah has decided to stop holding onto her life.
Carly falls to the floor and hugs the bag begging
for her mother to return. As the sun rises,
Sarah flies faster into the sky. With a smile on
her face, she tells her husband that she loves him
and puts the phone down. A while later, the
phone falls through the ceiling. The father
and the daughter hold each other and cry mourning
Sarah’s death. It is now a few weeks after the
incident. The family has repaired the ceiling.
Carly prepares tea and breakfast for both of them
and studies hard for her finals. Dave notices
a change in her behavior after Sarah’s death.
The movie ends as they eat the meal in silence.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out. Thanks for watching.